the nominees for performance by an  actress in a supporting role are  Margaret Avery in the color purple'  Angelica Huston in Prizzi's honor  amy madigan in twice in a lifetime  meg tilly and Agnes of God  Oprah Winfrey in the color purple  and the winner is Angelica Houston  I'd like to thank the members of the  Academy for honoring my fellow nominees  and myself this means a lot to me since  it comes from a role in which I was  directed by my father and I know it  means a lot to him  I'd also like to thank the entire cast  and crew of Prizzi's honor I don't want  to mention any names you know who you  are and to my friends for their love and  support and to my guardian angels  particularly Bruce Weintraub and my late  teacher miss Peggy Fury thank